My answer is it actually overshoots.
The problem is no matter how small this constant is over here,
It will eventually turns its wheels quite a bit towards it's trajectory.
Then it'll move towards a trajectory more and more,
and when it hits it, it's wheels will be straight,
but the robot itself will still be oriented a little bit downwards, so it's forced to overshoot.
What this means is that applied to a car, a P-controller will act like this.
It'll slightly overshoot, and that could be okay. The overshooting is very small.
But it'll never really converge.
It'll be what's called "marginally stable" or often just "stable" in the literature.